[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing for Friday
May 5th I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal the global market for
influencer advertising is expected to
surpass 21 billion dollars this year
according to influencer marketing hub
for family and parent accounts a lot of
the revenue they generate will come from
sharing pictures and stories of their
children but that raises a number of
questions from privacy concerns to who
gets to keep the money earned from these
posts our producer Zoe Culkin has been
looking into this and joins us now to
discuss legal efforts to address it Zoe
can you start by telling us have
children that have been the focus of
these kinds of accounts spoken about how
it is growing up in front of the camera
and how that's impacted them yeah so
vlogging and family vlogging is still
such a new career path so a lot of the
kids who have been affected by this are
still kids so it is difficult to gauge
with the long-term effects are but there
is a woman named cam Barrett who is now
in adult and her mom had a blog when she
was younger where she posted pictures
and intimate details of her childhood
here's what cam Barrett had to say while
she was testifying in front of the
Washington State Legislature I just want
to note that today is the first time
that I've introduced myself with my
legal name in three years because I'm
terrified to share my name because the
digital footprint I had no control over
exists
I apologize
when you Google my name simply just my
first name childhood photos of me in
bikinis will pop about you can hear the
pain and emotion in her voice teenagers
and young adults who kind of grew up
consuming this kind of content are
realizing the effects that it can have
on kids in the long term both in terms
of privacy like in the case with Cam
Barrett where she felt she was exploited
and had her privacy taken away from her
but also financially considering there
just aren't any clear rules that exist
right now to make sure that kids are
getting a cut of the content that their
parents are monetizing are lawmakers
anywhere in the country taking steps to
deal with these issues either the use of
Miners likenesses and posts or the
financial side where they aren't
necessarily receiving any of the money
from the monetized posts they're in so a
bill in Illinois and called SB 1782 is
currently circulating through the
state's government and it aims to
protect these child vloggers I was able
to speak with one of the co-sponsors
senator Dave Taylor about how this topic
got on his radar this is more widespread
than than certainly I realized this was
brought to me by a 15 year old student
from Normal Illinois and she's on
YouTube quite a bit she has seen a lot
of the vloggers that are out there and
she was concerned about it so she
contacted my office people all over I
said yeah this is a problem this needs
to be addressed somehow so we're trying
to address this so Zoe how does this
bill in Illinois try to address either
of these issues
how this bill works it helps to have a
little bit of background knowledge on
some existing federal law called
Coogan's law and a lot of people might
already be familiar with this but
Coogan's law protects child actors or
performers and it makes sure that
whatever money the child is earning when
they're acting or performing their
parents have to set aside a trust fund
for them contribute a certain percentage
of their income into that account that
they can then access when they reach a
certain age or the age of majority so SB
1782 is really aiming to do the same
thing just in the social media space so
vloggers whose children appear in 30 of
their paid content within a 30-day
period have to set aside a trust fund
and contribute a percentage and that
percentage is dependent on how many
children are present what the views are
the amount of time they spend in these
ads you know I feel like we keep talking
on this show about how influencing has
all these similar parties to Hollywood
and this just feels like the latest one
to be pointed out you're telling us
about this bill circulating in Illinois
are there efforts in any other states to
do something similar yeah so Illinois
actually borrowed the language of this
bill from a similar bill that started in
Washington state that bill did not get
passed when they were in last session
they are going to attempt again next
year but I have the chance to speak with
one of the co-sponsors representative
Christine Reeves about some of the
struggles that they faced in getting it
passed a majority of people currently
serving in the State House of
Representatives in Washington exist in a
time where social media has not been
their entire life and so for some of
them it is difficult to comprehend that
we would proactively be trying to solve
a problem on behalf of a generation that
in a lot of cases has just come of age
to vote right and so the work we have to
do is just to educate our colleagues on
why solving this problem matters and how
solving this problem is going to happen
in a bipartisan way it sounds like
representative Reeves is talking about
this generational divide maybe a
generational misunderstanding I wonder
if Illinois is facing any similar issues
to what Washington state had to deal
with yeah Illinois is definitely facing
some of those same problems and then
also other issues and areas of concern
recently an amendment was made because
the Department of Labor and some of
these tech companies and the legislators
themselves realize that it's not as easy
as it seems to follow through and
enforce a deletion of all content that a
minor was in for their entire childhood
that's a lot harder and a lot more goes
into that than just pressing a delete
button so in order to have a better
chance at getting this through that
aspect of deletion of likeness has been
amended so now the bill purely focuses
on the financial protection of these
children I asked Senator kaler about why
he decided to take the requirement that
platforms delete this content out of the
bill we didn't really want to make the
tech companies liable in that case
because that's just the vehicle the the
platform that the parents are using this
is a decision that's made by parents and
the the choose to put their children on
the internet and then they choose to
monetize it okay so what happens next
for these efforts in Illinois so SB 1782
is still moving through the state
government but as of now it was passed
unanimously in the Illinois Senate it
has a hearing in the house in the coming
weeks then it has to go back to the
Senate due to an amendment that was made
to kind of clear up some of the language
of what is vlogging and what is
monetization and then from then on when
it passes in both the house and the
Senate the governor has 60 days to make
a decision Senator kaler is really
optimistic that this is a good start it
would be ideal if of course the federal
government would pick this up and
Congress would pass something on this
because then it would be enforceable
throughout the United States but a lot
of times this kind of legislation starts
with the states and if we can do it if
Washington can come back and do it and
other states can realize that this is an
issue of our time then maybe we can get
some momentum going Zoe thanks for
bringing us this story thanks for having
me
[Music]
that was our producer Zoe Culkin and
that's it for Tech news briefing this
week tnb's producer is Julie Chang we
had production assistants from just
Jupiter and Zoe Culkin our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris sinsley I'm
your host Zoe Thomas thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
foreign